a safari in the pantanal the Earth's
largest tropical Wetlands tourists from
all over the world come to watch rare
birds and wildlife in the Brazilian
state of matogrosudu
two years ago a catastrophic fire
destroyed much of this green Paradise
leaving a trail of Destruction and
killing millions of native species
Farmers have always cleared their lands
with fire but the intensity of the fires
we've seen in the last year is not
common it's a consequence of the worst
drought in a century caused by
deforestation in the Amazon and
extensive farming
Brazil witnessed a peak of deforestation
in the Amazon in 2021 13 000 square
kilometers were destroyed reaching a
14-year High
environmentalists fear that if
bothordaro wins the October 30th runoff
he'll continue pushing for legislation
to open up protected areas for Mining
and farming as he said he would
president bolsonaro's government has
already dismantled and defunded public
organizations in charge of controlling
the preservation of the environment the
pantanal is the size of many European
countries if there's no protection it
will eventually dry out bolsonando's
left-wing rival Forum president luisi
nasululla Da Silva has been criticized
in the past for the construction of the
controversial Balo monche hydropower dam
in the Amazon it displaced some forty
thousand people
but Lola did Implement environmental
policies dramatically reducing
deforestation and is promising to
rebuild government institutions that
control illegal activities in the Amazon
judging how Brazilians voted in the
first round the environment is far from
being a priority
four out of every 10 congressmen elected
are against strict laws limiting
economic activity in protected areas
these charcoal colored tree trunks are
the scars of an intense fire that passed
through this Forest three years ago it
took firefighters 40 days to control the
flames and even though scarce rain
helped the pantanal flourish this may
well be a temporary respite the future
of the pantanal and the Amazon May well
depend on the outcome of Sunday's
election and on the capability of the
next president to find a balance between
defending nature while promoting much
needed economic growth Monica yanakev Al
Jazeera pantanau Brazil